what's the most common mistake you see
people make over and over
i think the most common i mean this is a
very
tough question because it's so
contextual right it really depends on
the context
um i think the most common mistake if i
look at out there in on planet earth
like for humanity
is the idea or the belief that you're
going to be made happy because of some
external circumstance
uh and i know that's not original that's
not new that's fundamental buddhist
wisdom so i'm not taking credit for it
but i think i really just recognize it
as a fundamental level including in
myself like we just bought a new car we
have a baby so we need a safer car we
were driving a little mini cooper before
not enough room in there um so we bought
a new car and now i'm waiting for the
new car to arrive and of course every
night i'm on the forums reading about
the car why am i doing that it's a silly
object a silly car it's not going to
change my life that much or at all and i
know that the instant the car arrives i
won't care about it anymore yeah but
what it is i'm addicted to the desiring
i mean
i'm addicted to the idea that this
external thing is going to bring me some
kind of happiness and joy and that's
just completely delusional
um so i think just looking outside for
anything
i think it is the fundamental delusion i
i which is not to say you shouldn't do
things on the outside you absolutely
should you're
you're a living creature uh you you know
there are things that you do you locally
reverse entropy that's why you're here
you're meant to do something you're not
just meant to lie there in the sand and
meditate all day long so you should
self-actualize and you should do what
you're meant to do but the idea that
you're going to change something in the
outside world and that is going to bring
you the peace and everlasting joy and
the happiness that you deserve that is a
fundamental delusion that we all suffer
from including me and so the mistake
over and over and over is to say oh i'll
be happy when i get that thing whatever
that is that's the fundamental mistake
that we all make including me 24 7 all
day long
i definitely see myself from that answer
because you're because you're human
you're human
all of us do it
what does freedom mean to you
freedom is freedom from the mind
the only reason that any human being is
not free is because of his mind
it is the mind which creates his
tortures
it is the mind which creates his
anxieties it is the mind which creates
his conflicts
it is the mind which creates his rules
all that he is confined by all that he
is imprisoned by is the mind not
anything else
when i was young i wanted freedom but i
wanted freedom in the sense of i didn't
want to be trapped in the house i wanted
to be able to live where i wanted i
wanted to be able to make money i wanted
to have a girlfriend i wanted to go to a
place where i could do whatever i wanted
whenever i wanted that's what i wanted
in my mind freedom was just getting away
from physical constraints and material
constraints
i got all that stuff i traveled with the
whole world i ate all the food i made
all the money
i got all the things that i wanted in
life
yet the quality of my life did not
change that much the quality of my
moment-to-moment experience didn't
change that much that's because i hadn't
changed that much my internal experience
was still very much the same every time
i got something i wanted the next thing
and wanted the next thing and one of the
next thing
all the same pains and tortures and
miseries were still there maybe some
were better obviously it's better to be
rich than to be poor it's better to be
healthy than to be sick but beyond a
certain point
my baseline level of peace had not
changed that much
then i started making a transition to
what you're talking about realizing that
a lot of these traps were in my mind but
you just jumped all the way you're
saying no it's all from the mind from
the very beginning
yes any freedom that leads to the desire
for more freedom is not freedom if
there's a bleed you don't clean the
tributary vessels you want to look at
the source of the bleed
even if it took someone 30 years
to learn the source of the bleed to
learn the truth about what freedom
really was it would be far more
effective
to begin that journey at this very
second as opposed to doing it piecemeal
because that'll take 900 years it is not
abstract to say that freedom comes from
the mind
what it is is revelatory
the belief is
that anxiety and fears and pain arise
from circumstance
that they arise from other people
as long as that belief is invested
inside of someone
he will spend his life trying to change
circumstance
and that will be a monumental waste of
life and you only get one
so quite frankly there isn't enough time
to go piecemeal
it is far better to not understand than
it is to go piecemeal because then
you're going down a tributary
and that tributary leads to other
tributaries very soon you're way off
course
what we're really talking about here is
that all of the problems that we
struggle with we tend to externalize we
tend to solve them in the external world
and there are certain ones that are
practical in the external world do i
have food do i have shelter those kinds
of things but beyond a certain basic
level a lot of the problems we're trying
to solve in the external world are
actually internal problems and even if
we manage to solve the current
manifestation in the external world the
new problem will just pop up tomorrow in
the external world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you